okay four people joining this livestream
this is our weekly language completeness
and consistency meeting and we will be
talking about a variety of topics
hopefully about language completeness
and consistency for from language okay
let's take a look at the first even
before you dive in I'm going Michael is
tied up in external meetings so I mean I
would suggest we start with the force
forth agenda item and work our way up
okay fine
so we tweaked to read string [ __ ] oh
this is horrifying right so right so
there's an this option type constraint
that tarley and the person who went off
to Google or whose name escapes me at
the moment yes Renaud introduced to
added this option to read string time
constraint when they added processes
external processes but of course they
only added it for their external
processing so if you try to use it with
a regular file i/o we're dealing with it
with a pipe basically it's not correct
or with a process it's a process object
okay
and so they dealt with this case here
read string of proc yep okay so they did
not deal with reads I mean I don't even
know what it means for read string of
stream I mean what does it mean what is
the time to change so axis wall clock
time is this what is this yes as
implemented this is and I don't know
right I mean the question is right so
read string I mean I suppose if you have
a humongous file it might take several
seconds I mean I'm not sure what or you
know I'm not sure what the use case
first of all I'm not entirely sure I
know what the use case is so I know you
are I'll read what about reading from
URL or does this not even do that I
think
should work because you know you are
because yes I mean if I say read string
um if I say read string of URL and it's
not documented for sure yeah I don't
think well the URL may or may not work
but yeah where does it worked fine yeah
okay so by the way that should get
documented right uh it may be in a note
down below but ya know it doesn't look
like it's even documented so okay so I
probably should say read string of URL
should be another item here um now what
is the term thing do until the
Terminator right so I mean if I if I
said this let me check whether it works
and if I said quotes UTF gosh eight I
can see one of those in there you want
the yeah magnificent okay that's great
okay now clearly time constraint makes
sense for URL reading yep um one of the
issues here is whether it returns what
it's read by that time it's correct and
this what it's saying here is completely
hopeless and unacceptable it cannot do
vastly different things right so
basically my opinion is we don't change
the doc and we basically fix read string
to behave consistently now that's not a
small project by any means what I want
it to do I mean reading look that this
thing that we have in the device
framework we have this buffer reading
concept where it does return what it
read so far but I don't think any of the
other functions return what they've read
so far do they constraint generally
causing a port if it fails
time constraint in most well not
necessarily like simplify has a time
constraint and basically that just means
you know skip that simplification and
and go on to the next possible
simplification after that time
constraint so it's not an absolute rule
and I would also make a distinction
between time ran out and so we're going
to give up versus time ran out and so
we're going to stop reading now but the
stream still exists and so one could
imagine continuing to read later okay
exactly
alright but so let's understand what it
means okay so the fact is I could
imagine you know we've got that
Terminator concept there and the
Terminator you know I could imagine like
an automatic terminator which means read
as far as you can did that one exists
it's called end of buffer it's right
there on the third line of the does not
block and returns whatever is available
so it isn't quite the same thing but
it's a similar concept so what I'm
saying is I could imagine something
where read string source comma automatic
you know a time constraint I my initial
gut feeling is that the default behavior
for all of the different reading sources
should be time constraint if it blows
out the time constraint it returns
aborted because it's like then then you
know code that relies on oh did it read
as such-and-such will correctly fail
okay but then what I would suggest is
that there could be a version of it that
says you know like read string to the
automatic Terminator and the automatic
Terminator is in effect wherever it
reached after a certain time so I'm
saying because I personally think that
is the less common case I think
the more common cases you're trying to
read a string and you asked did it
contain a I don't know you know did it
contain some some particular did it
contain an elephant or something you
know did contain a particular word orang
or a new line say yes that's a very
common case right um
and to know you know to get something
back that's well this is the gulp I got
but it didn't do that I mean you know to
know whether it contains a new line you
basically say read to the Terminator
does it does it read to that Terminator
I feel like the way that we could do
this is with the time constraint with a
terminator being automatic okay so the
next question is if you say we'd to a
terminator
yeah it should just fail if you say read
string comma newline and it runs out of
the time constraint it should just abort
it should not try and give you something
which doesn't have the correct
terminator yes so my proposal here would
be that the correct design is read
strings sauce comma automatic or you
could say instead you could have a
symbolic name in addition to automatic
there okay that means read until you run
out of time and then a time constraint
that that specifies you know how long to
wait that would be my suggestion I could
even imagine a situation where you'd
have a third argument at the time but I
think it's better to have a time
constraint probably mmm-hmm sense to
people
and we don't want to return something
like a failure object that would contain
the what was read so far but would be a
failure of aborted or something yeah I
mean I don't think that would be
terrible
i I don't have strong opinions about
that if if that's implementable I think
that might be interesting is that is
what we just described implementable or
not right so I mean adding the new
behavior of time constraint that returns
you know what's been read thus far - for
arbitrary files and streams is not a
simple project Garrett was working on it
with David lebryk before he left I don't
know what the state of that code is and
and you know let's look at it doesn't
seem like the most urgent thing in the
world right but making it return I mean
I guess Stefan should be here and be
able to opine on this but I think that
making it return aborted in all cases
should probably be pretty
straightforward
the only possible issue is you know what
what about downstream breakage caused by
this change in behavior but we have to
look up somebody's going to look at the
code so doing that it should be fairly
simple but yeah I'm not sure about the
fallout from what I can tell at least in
our code base the time constraints
option isn't really used much okay
alright are there any other functions
that behaves similarly to read string I
think everything in the reads them at
every thing in the reads family so read
lying read lists but I don't you don't
know that for a fact I mean I don't
think import string makes any sense
so it doesn't make sense I mean import
possibly but not import string well I
think that all of these things I do
think import might make sense
I could imagine formats where I mean if
this is if it aborts I mean you just
wrap time-constrained around it if you
really care so long as it actually
aborts correctly through the whole chain
of external processes and so on and if
it can't do that then adding the option
isn't really gonna help bring indeed all
right good
ok it sounds like we're we're wrapped on
this particular issue yep ok previous
one so their system cache ok so this is
so there are two proposed changes here
if you look at the clear system cache
dogs
closed system cash is such a scary
concept so there are two notes right and
so and so I sort of objected this way of
formatting things because it means the
auto the auto in for auto completions
code can't refer it right you know can't
find it right you need to be able to you
know say clear system cache of cash
clears only the specified cash and then
have a little table of you know numeric
symbolic sure what are the caches right
so there there's a list there of various
caches that exist and you know I
personally would be ok with documenting
all of them I'm you know we might want
to run a couple of the more obscure ones
by by the relevant developer right so
all of these work right now is what
you're saying
correct okay okay is this really okay
what is the real use case for this thing
okay so well what one of them is you
know free up memory in which case
probably new American symbolic are your
two you know your to go to guys with
other I noticed that Brian I live stream
agrees with me that we're turning data
when aborting is a bad idea so you know
we have some of the relevant developer I
mean derivative that's one I actually
use because if you sort of define your
own derivatives sometimes something will
be cached and then when you redefine it
you know doesn't anybody how would any
user ever know that I mean that's
something we should fix in the
derivative assignment code not expect
people to do a clear system cache
okay okay I can't even imagine what is
the molecule system cash doing well
whenever you read you know molecules are
sort of big atomic object so every time
you create a molecule it's done
what's that yeah no pun intended right
but they have this huge data structure
backing them and you don't want to have
to recreate that every time so right
there's this cache of molecules you've
created so if you type in the same
molecule in a different format it just
goes and you know assigns it to the
right molecule so again it's you know
you want to free up memory it's ID you
know all of these are sort of now I
don't know if American and symbolic I
don't know it's the American symbolic
these names are very inconsistent
molecule versus symbolic just doesn't
cut it
mm-hmm I mean I think that if we're
gonna do that we should rename these you
know we can leave the American symbolic
working but but you know something like
molecule data symbolic data I don't know
something like that it means it's just
because otherwise I have no idea what
this is I mean quantity I don't know
what that is is that is that it's the
it's the parsing short name so if you
say quantity F T we're not reversing all
the time but we still want to have a
first so ash wanted a interpretation is
that Y would be a repetitions yeah I
think if we're gonna have this these
names have to be a lot clearer okay and
it may be useful to go to system options
there is some information there just
click in so that those are the
parameters now in the in the example the
example shows the parameters of each of
the classes oh my gosh that's funky
and where might we by the way this type
of information why is this not in system
information well system information
generally gives information about the
host not about it's also information
about the configuration isn't it don't
think it gives that much about you know
yeah the kernel states a right it does I
mean it says what you've loaded and
whatnot but it's not like it gives you
you know your you know system options or
or you know what your you know what your
what's in your in it dot M say right it
says you know what your license ideas
and no no no look at some of the things
that hasn't it
I mean it's got oh well this is not
system information this is preferences
well so all right but let's look at
system information yeah I mean I can
think of graphics drivers which are
configurable with options to the
front-end but that's that's stole all
right of hardware and external software
ok fair enough
yeah ok all right ok so I take back that
comment um all right but these I mean to
me this is pretty you know by the time
user code is using any of the stuff um
you know there's a lot of terrifying
things um right I mean I
right I mean well and I mean I I don't
have a strong preference about
documenting these additional ones or not
I personally think if we're gonna have
them exist and we're gonna have them
written out in places like this that and
why it isn't an association of no idea
but anyway we're gonna have them written
out let's give them real names and let's
document them okay um so figure out what
their names should be okay all right are
we where are we going to next the obj1
obj2 right so this is something when we
rewrote information for version 12 was
missed because it wasn't documented on
Rev / information but if you very
carefully read tutorial / operator input
forms you would see that question mark
of you know symbol ones space symbol -
was documented and you know would print
out the information for each symbol it's
not totally obvious what it should
return right because the old information
just printed information as a side
effect and the new information actually
returns a quería below object so they
were trying to call them and why doesn't
it what let's just understand what this
says so if I say question mark grad
mm-hmm okay it returns that creature
there mm-hmm
so I would claim that so you know I
don't quite understand because that's
not just some formatted thing that's a
queryable expression so what's the
queryable expression that this returns I
mean does it return a list of things all
of a sudden I mean it conceivably could
I mean I think the the the to option the
to realistic options in my opinion are
either we don't you know we just remove
the documentation and this is the new
behavior or you know maybe we can figure
out like when you do with the pattern
right you get this
that gives you you know what why does
anybody care about this behavior I mean
I think this behavior existed for
terminal interfaces in the very very
very distant past right which is why I
was which is why I'm perfectly okay it
just means we need to update the
documentation I just want want you know
since this is documentation you wrote
and you're a little touchy about that I
wanted to check with you before I'm just
thinking about I'm thinking about the
actual case of terminal mm-hmm do we
care there I mean if I actually run you
know um if I run wolfram script here
mm-hmm I mean let me just see what
happens if I say question mark grad not
the most beautiful thing in the world
what the heck is that that's a mess well
it's right it's giving you the formatted
message and output form yeah but a
goofed up look which I think has to do
with the fact that we changed it from
being a side effect that's printed to a
returned object so it has to it's now
subjected to line breaking inside of so
it's just a goof up here but but it's
just some weird spacing right because
you can see that the one is in the right
place but that but the first n is
shifted a little bit too far over and I
think this might I know it's the fact
that the ellipsis is or well yeah I'm
betting it's that the ellipsis is one
character instead of three right how did
that happen
well I so there is a known bug which
this may be a manifestation of that the
the the the the code is counting bytes
rather than characters so when you have
a non ASCII character like an ellipsis
in there it's putting in sort of two
spaces and you know the partial is
putting in probably three spaces so we
should try to fix it mm-hmm otherwise my
question was going to be did you just
happen to discover
while staring at documentation this
question mark simple simple syntax or
was this based on feedback from me yeah
you know if there's a bug report from a
user then it seems more important than
yeah they're there there's no bug report
I was just updating something else in
the documentation and I noticed that got
two things going on here so I personally
think we can just deprecated the double
okay question mark double simple thing I
think that that now whether we want to
deprecated it for the terminal front end
I'm not telling winter face I'm not so
sure um let's just look at it oh I see
it doesn't work anymore I I think we
could live without it I I don't see a
important term important issue yes
Sandra on the live stream is pointing
out I mean if we if we if it's in in an
output form we didn't have the ellipses
B and ellipsis character then we
wouldn't have this problem but I think
we need to solve this bites versus you
know what I'm saying this problem and
bites versus characters yes okay all
right let's move on um okay so yay
Michael has arrived so we can discuss
the first item yeah no worries so right
so this has to do with the formatting of
the new information and its utility for
code and I thought there were some
examples in here but maybe ok what's the
basic issue the basic issue two small
form fund yeah
two small and proportional spacing what
are the basic issues
can we see an example so I just sent you
a notebook Stephen just now with a
couple of examples also showing some
options to change it around
yeah that's gonna goof up I agree this
was we didn't think about this properly
bad idea
yeah and so the next section just
basically shows using code font in place
and the next one after that shows
increasing the font size a bit other
things we can do to play around with it
do we have anybody from design here
Billy Billy is here yep okay um this
doesn't quite look right with the word
definitions in the way what are the
other possible left hands I mean I think
we're gonna have to change the way the
word definitions looks just get away
with using this different font yeah so I
was thinking also John had floated the
idea of having an opener to show the
definition so like if you do information
of plot since there are so many options
we have a an opener and closer to keep
the pod from getting super big and we
could potentially have something like
that it's also a little bit of a stuff
or sort of space to not start under the
definition yes okay so this here has
proportional font
hmm
well it makes me think that just like
this usage at the top is sort of special
that the definition could similarly be
special
so I'm saying I mean you can go on with
things so in other words we have a kind
of a sandwich here of there's the top
thing I mean I this is not I'm not that
wild about the look of that thing at the
tournament that full name is down there
below so yeah if in this case it's just
the the usage gets used by default and
since there's no usage for the custom
defined function its replicated here
yeah I get it and I think that's kind of
goofy but but well whatever
look what I'm suggesting is get rid of
the word definitions or put the
definitions as Michael says on top
somehow make it full with make it a
sandwich of some kind
there's potentially also up values and
sub values where we could do the same
notion with that um right so we could
have like alternating rows right so rows
with definition with some color which is
an open or and closer and then you know
the next guy white background all the
definitions wave what are you saying I
mean what I'm saying is and this is
something for Billy it's basically just
like the usage up here is special on are
we on a different background
similarly for definitions get rid of the
definitions were we don't say here usage
right here we just give it okay and the
suburbs up values you can see whether
the suburbs are up though is because you
can see what the definition is so to
speak and we can have a separator line I
don't think we need to label them down
value somebody's up values and so on
and what about format values numeric
values say format of F comma or whatever
on the left hand side well right you
know I suppose we could do this it's
just right so you're saying that all the
definitions and so what just options and
attributes remain and documentation yeah
remains that I mean look all these kinds
of things all these extras can remain in
the in the you know proportional font as
they are here but I'm just saying in the
sandwich I mean for plot there won't be
an additional definition section right
great this is for functions I'm
suggesting that you have the definitions
area I think we should see some designs
where the definitions are it could even
just be on white here with another
separator line before you get to
documentation etc right okay and I just
sent you like a quick thing of the
definitions thing plopped under there of
this short sandwich I don't know if she
wanted you to see there real quick yeah
I mean the two things you lose by remove
the word definitions is you don't is
right you first of all don't make it
clear that you can query that property
and also but we see this from Billy okay
I get that point that makes some sense
and and the other is that if you have a
lot of definitions than having them sort
of nicely grouped is is helpful
well this doesn't look that bad this
really doesn't look that bad mmm-hmm I
don't have an objection to this actually
I said along the lines of what you're
thinking Michael something like that
yeah it shouldn't be hard to do
district-wide let's get let's get a
final spec for this and looks looks like
we can have a simple solution here okay
good okay next item so this is yeah this
is really of an open discussion that I a
I have sort of a vague suggestion but
it's a big sort of thorny problem so
suppose we have some huge object like
range of 10 to the 9th and message so
right now I guess what happens is it
goes through to the default format or
for messages which will attempt to make
boxes it which will first of all unpack
it and so you'll have to wait for it
make unpack and then it does all the
things that shorten it so you know you
wait two minutes to basically see you
know dot parentheses dot dot dot or or
somesuch
so we don't even want really to send it
to the front end so maybe above if if an
object is above a certain size maybe we
store
in the variable and we put in some
really simple suggestion why aren't we
running short on the object in the
kernel before we send it to the
front-end we are and that unpacks it and
then make boxes all of it and that's
crazy I don't understand this I mean if
I say short of you know let's say I say
short of 10 to the 6 or something range
of 10 to the 6
mm-hmm okay
what is that object that object if I
look at the input form of that offf is
short of 10 to the 6 and you know oh
gosh yeah oh gosh okay that's crazy okay
so we need a version of short it's not
crazy it's 100% consistent with the
definition that is all right so so we
need a genuine short basically that
doesn't even bother to send the stuff
because this is just a message this is
not okay okay I've got actually a claim
here okay just like I can eyes okay this
is okay so can I can I steal with remote
data can it do that yet so in other
words No okay so that is something we
could also imagine it doing
just like data set just like audio can
have this not stored in the notebook you
know remote data that's in a local
object we can imagine doing that for I
can eyes that make sense sure but this
seems far too heavyweight I mean my
suggestion so first of aii object to
your suggestion for two reasons one it
doesn't exist and B what what what well
your original suggestion of just the
version of short that completely
shortens everything you know my
suggestion was going to be something
along the lines of you know
we have something that you know saves it
and available and give formats you as a
little thing so if you actually need to
know what was that enormous object that
was not part of the message you know how
to get it okay I don't like that
solution for the following reason the
thing is never going to get garbage
collected once that message is in you
know is showing up in the notebook I
don't even know how we would untangle it
I don't know how we know it wasn't
referenced if you happen to delete that
cell it's very hard for it to crawl back
and find out that that variable is no
longer referenced anywhere right which
is why what I'm suggesting is my top
suggestion here is it's a frigging
message you just care what it looks like
right
you know first approximation I think
that's not a bad point of view and if
you only care what it looks like you
just don't have to transmit or store any
of that giant backing data that that's
not always true though I get pretty
frustrated when my journaling messages
gets truncated precisely at the
interesting point okay well fine so
that's why I was starting to suggest
these things about I can eyes with
backing information but but look let's
let's okay the the number one problem is
things okay okay could we imagine a
situation well let's see I don't
understand how you would get rid of the
data so in other words let's say you
have backing that is the the billion
element list or something okay that's
stored somewhere but yet you actually
don't care about a little how do you get
rid of it you know how long should it
live that you so you know in case so
right so I guess I guess the short
answer is first of all presumably well I
guess in a lot of cases certainly not
all cases but in a lot of cases the
message is in the the large thing which
and the message is also in the in the
returned expressions unless dollar
history length is equal to zero it's not
going to be correct I don't think you
can count on that at all tons of
examples where it would be in the
intermediate things but not in the
output I agree if it's in the output you
can point to it I don't have a problem
with that if there's some sort of
relation to my my claim isn't that we
could point to it in the output my claim
is that worrying about garbage
collection is pointless unless we're
setting history length to zero I know
but I think the vast majority of cases
know if you look at the bug reports that
people care about then it's precisely
those cases we have to solve the case
where it's an intermediate expression
Brett you were going to say something
yeah I was saying that I'm wondering
whether there's any relationship between
this and how the front end deals with
undo and things that aren't I match it
up anymore
whether there's some clever way of using
a similar type of tracking of what needs
to still be around or not I don't know
there's anybody from fronton team here
well John was supposed to be here but I
don't see him so maybe he's out today
trying to try and track him it down
please Louis here yes but I can't speak
to the details of the crypto hash
implementation of grain down outputs
which is I think what Brett was
referring to right okay but but okay it
is my strong suggestion that what we do
is have a version of short that doesn't
transmit the data now what are the
objections to this Jeremy's objection is
maybe you'll lose the great thing that
you really want it
I mean and and be fair we already lose
it and so you know I have to play with
okay dollar message free print and
reevaluate anyway there are two they're
two things that we have here okay
there's what is visually worth seeing
and there's what will blow the brains of
the front end out okay and those are
somewhat different sizes in other words
we could in fact transmit more than you
see just not transmit the whole thing so
I have one other question which is how
does this relate to what you see when
you view the stack trace through the
message
that's good question what do you mean I
mean is it possible to have a strictly
shortened version of the thing in the
message and have it but when you view
the stack trace the stack trace by the
way the stack trace the expressions are
guaranteed to still exist that true
statement no I don't maybe that isn't
Lou how does that work well they're
stored specifically I'm not sure what
you mean by still exist I mean not be
not having been garbage collected but a
copy of the stack trace is explicitly
stored when a message is generated yes
how does that work when the message is
huge it I mean it's it does not store
the entire stack it goes through and
carefully prunes the stack based on
several conversations you and I and
others have had over the years okay
storing gigabytes of stuff okay listen
I'm coming back again to my strong
recommendation that we simply have a
version of short that genuinely shortens
I mean that basically just is the output
from short and that's it
you know it is the expression you know
we could imagine I don't know what the
what the way to describe it is short for
real so to speak where the output is
simply the box's structure that
corresponds to this thing now we could
do something where to in a little bit
more ornately we could do something
where it has you know one level of drill
down but then just loses it after that
or we could just for simplicity we could
just have a genuine shortening I think
that's what we should do I think that we
could try and make some very elaborate
scheme that still stores the data um and
I think that you know will then run into
other issues and I just don't think it's
that important I think if people really
want it they can rerun their code with
an echo or something like this
comments
etai will correct me if I'm wrong but I
think the issue is not that short
returns the wrong boxes it's that it
takes so long to return the right boxes
correct I mean they're yes the boxes
that short generates are small I mean if
you look if you do two boxes of fruit of
you know percent 47 you'll see that the
boxes are quite small the problem is
that it takes you know minutes to
generate those boxes why because first
it because that's the way but short
works in the Box world it makes the
boxes and then it shortens them okay so
okay
and if rewriting that from scratch were
easy it would have been done already but
it's not okay so I wrote the original
version of short back in 1988 or
something right which has nothing to do
with the version of short that exists in
the world I understand that why are we
using the Box world to generate the
messages output why are we not using the
output form world because we're
displaying it and printing it in a
front-end but we could in fact generate
a string here if that's the I mean if we
see that the expression is absolutely
huge I mean we're dealing with a corner
case here mm-hmm which is a thing that's
absolutely huge right so so basically so
so your suggestion is basically if I
will make a more concrete version of
your suggestion which is basically if
the object is larger than say the
history that's them the large output
limiter limit then rather than doing a
normal short on it we do to string of
short of the thing to get the fast quick
short that's what I'm suggesting yes I
mean it's easy to implement it will
prevent the thing blowing up which is
what we most care about
it is not the most elegant solution I
think going forward some point we really
need to deal with the lighted
expressions now that we have icon eyes
and I can eyes has been quite successful
I think we need to deal with the
possibility of having a short where you
can click here and see more of it and so
on and I think that's the thing we
should be looking at there's an ILD
project ok it's something that's been on
the list for like a decade to have a
lighted expressions with all you know
doors and click and drill down and so on
um I think the right way to deal with
triaging the current issue is what I'm
saying and what you're saying but but if
you actually did have a to string of
short in the middle of an expression
then exponents and stuff would get
aligned completely incorrectly right
we'd have to do something with
subscripts and superscripts to not have
the traditional output form formatting
mess them up right ok yes I understand
you've got it you've got a string the
string has a certain bounding area I
mean it's not the most beautiful thing
in the world but I think it's it's some
you know I mean it would also be good to
have a version of short in the box world
I had no idea that it actually generated
all the boxes and then shortened I
didn't even know it did that I mean I
don't understand why there isn't at
least basic you know you know things
like very long lists and it's rather
easy to get that to work I would think
well and the short answer to your
question is because if you if you drop
arbitrary sub elements and then make
boxes that you're likely to produce
pinking if you say have a graphics in
there or any of the number of other I
understand stacks I understand so it has
to be done with a bit more care I mean I
would think that there has to be in the
tree of boxes you have to you know
remove only sprue known out only certain
sub trees Thanks and anybody looked at
this anytime in the last 25 years this
is you yes
which is why I say if it were easy to
fix it would have been fixed already ok
so what did you find when you looked
into it
I mean well I the short conclusion is we
would probably need to rewrite short
from scratch
or to make boxes world okay how
complicated is that I mean I remember
when I wrote short originally it is
slightly clever what the code does in
some cases so I know it isn't completely
trivial it's I well the short answer is
I don't exactly know but I think it
would take me several months full-time
working on it that seems hard to believe
I remember the original version of short
admittedly it's in a slightly simpler
formatting environment was you know it
took a few days but it wasn't it was not
anything of that order right but you
didn't have to worry about template
boxes that's true I would like okay
listen and then let me just I'm sorry
but I mean one of the complications is
right swart right has the second
argument of sort of how many lines you
want and in a lot of cases the kernel
has no idea how long an expression is
because only the front end knows how
it's actually how these boxes are going
I don't I would like to put this on the
list of things that we really should
look at because look okay elided
expressions is the general category we
should look at that this particular
thing about short is obviously not worth
putting a huge amount of effort into
short as such so how it is the general
part of a lighted expressions I think we
should look at it and if we can get to
that in the next few months that would
be a good thing to at least try and do a
design about elided expressions but
dealing with this particular issue let's
try and do the best we can using two
string of short okay I think that's
probably something you can do in in a
few minutes
if you yes okay great all right next
item so this was just I don't know I
thought there was something there but
this was just an email you said
wanted to discuss and and so we're
bonkers I mean what was happening right
now is bonkers so the issue is and thus
I guess is an issue for Brett right and
I mean presumably it's just a bug and as
soon as I see what the example is then
well I don't know I think if you do any
graphics row of let's say table graphics
rectangle aspect ratio random real zero
- we like to say zero - why not that'll
be fine it won't give you actual zero so
okay what's going on look at look inside
this one here okay what is going on with
that space thing what why is their
spacing why is there a bunch of space
there this is a graphics row why is it
why is it equal spacing some of these
things well isn't it just that the
graphics is I mean it's the white space
of the graphics can you give those
graphics background goes to random color
I just want to see something
hey no it's not what I was expecting at
all yeah okay so that's the there I
drilled to the rectangle why is there so
what what the heck is that what is that
outer boundary there what is that I mean
I'm guessing that it's padding so they
all have the same shape which is
probably required for the table case
yeah but it's not right and you know
presumably there's a corresponding thing
for a graphics column yeah but this just
seems wrong right it just shouldn't be
padded I mean I can make this even more
extreme and outrageous if you want me to
by by making this um if I go out to like
six here or something we'll get no no I
didn't do it well no he so did oh it's
still I'm sorry I what I want is more I
want the distribution that goes down so
actually I want this only two to one or
something yeah now it now it's going
bonkers again Reds okay I think this is
wrong so then if I understand it just
shouldn't be any padding there right
simple as that
yeah I think that's possible it
shouldn't be a big change okay and I
think this was broken at some point I I
don't think it was always this way I
think this is a recent piece of breakage
well maybe well there were there were
updates version 12 uncle can you try it
with alignment goes to Center for which
for the row either one
now that's the 312 code so okay I think
you just have a bug yep okay
from DMS taking a list of coordinate
lists so this was another email you send
I suppose was a might yes I agree this
is something I forgot to implement you
know that all of the functionality takes
a race from the misses should also and
is there also a two DMS that should take
arranged then there is a DMS list and a
domestic ok Santa says that padding was
driving him nuts well good I'm glad I
was not independently insane about this
um okay Steven you're always uniquely
insane but I guess sometimes you're not
independently and saying okay um yeah it
still didn't help right I mean that's
the really bad case spacings to zero
should not have any space here right so
if the add dividers goes to all I mean I
guess it won't change anything it'll
just sort of help pinpoint you know sort
of make obvious oh I see okay it's not
so some of them are padded and some of
them are not okay all of them are padded
it's just whether it's vertically or
horizontally to bug let's get it right
and so after the change there will be no
space between them and all of them will
have the same height right yep okay all
the rectangles will have the same height
so they'll have different widths yes
tied up against one another yeah and
these so you're saying these things here
will be their full height
I'm saying it will look like one big
black rectangle yeah that's the correct
thing if you say spacings to zero yep
okay so Sanders saying item aspect ratio
will sometimes fix it wow that's useful
to know fixing it oh it's not fixing it
else bizarre yeah it's common shape but
it's not alright okay I think we have
what we need
um okay very good
we are done for today I'm alright and uh
[Music]
yes
Oh for tomorrow if people are interested
there's an ILD meeting and there's also
should be one about external storage
that will be live-streamed and possibly
one about code assistants